dans une atmosphère un milieu du tumulte
de la violence et de l'anarchie qui
régnait dans la même enceinte
il y a un an jour pour jour sénateurs et
représentants ont observé un moment de
recueillement
tour à tour ils ont réaffirmé le
caractère sacré du lieu et leur
attachement à la démocratie américaine
la vice-présidente a décrit toute la
violence de l'attaqué
et
hayden ce n'était rien de moins at elle
dit qu'un assure contre nos institutions
nos valeurs et nos idéaux dans un
discours d'une rare dureté et sans
jamais prononcer son nom le président
bedie ne s'en est vivement pris à son
prédécesseur et kanye west
il ne peut accepter qu'il a perdue at il
accusé c'est un menteur un assoiffé de
pouvoir un homme qui fait passer son
intérêt personnel avant celui de son
pays mais kg ce brunch d'igor
dans son esprit pour le moindre doute
donald trump est directement responsable
de ce qui s'est passé le 6 janvier 2021
il a fait ce qu'aucun président avant
lui n'avait fait en cherchant à miner la
démocratie américaine se créer l'heure
est grave ont répété en choeur de
nombreux démocrates jamais a dit celui
ci je n'ai été aussi inquiets
dans notre homme qui devait initialement
donner la réplique en conférence de
presse a riposté par communiqué accusant
joe barton d'instrumentaliser son nom
pour diviser les américains les membres
de sa garde rapprochée ont entonné le
même refrain
on nous dit femme sans vergogne
déplore-t-elle évoquant même un coup
monté du fbi un gain des républicains
ont choisi de faire profil bas en ce
jour de commémoration et ceux qui se
sont exprimés ont soufflé le chaud et le
froid dénonçant les débordements de
l'homme renier tout en reprochant aux
démocrates de chercher à tirer profit de
la situation
ici hugo lavallée radio-canada
washington